voilà avec romain de guerre et toute
l'équipe du figaro lifestyle nous vous
accueillons aujourd'hui à l'hôtel prince
de galles prince de galles c'était le
futur edouard 8 roi d'angleterre
petit fils de la reine victoria qui
deviendra un jour le duc de windsor et
c'est pour lui qu'a été construit en
1929 il ya exactement 80 10 ans cet
hôtel d'exception au coeur de paris on y
va merci entrer dans un palace c'est un
peu comme entrer dans un monde où tout
le monde il est beau tout le monde il
est gentil merci beaucoup
dès qu'on regarde quelqu'un il vous
sourit et ici au prince de galles ça
fait 80 disant qu'on sourit aux clients
et quel client wiston churchill qu'a
rencontrées dans les salons léon blum
gary cooper rita hayworth pablo picasso
marlène dietrich elvis presley
chostakovitch ou dalida dont l'hôtel
était dit-on son refuge une rampe qui
l'ont tenu à fauteuil ou se sont assis
ses légendes du siècle c'est la mémoire
de l'hôtel ça patine sa gloire sa
nostalgie
le toit d'un palace c'est un peu son
paradis c'est là qu'on met les plus
belles champ parce que c'est là qu'il ya
la plus belle vue
alors ici au huitième étage la maison
lalique signe sa première suite d'hôtel
dans un palace parisien
on a sauté à offrir une expérience
unique et exceptionnel aux clientes en
deux fleurons de l'art déco qui a su
traverser les époques et sont vraiment
des maisons au style intemporel qui ont
des savoir faire traditionnels aux
services de design et de services
d'aujourd'hui laluque ça vous dit
quelque chose quand même du noir de lors
du verre
voilà le petit mixte iconique de ce
célèbre verrier que ne disent pas
l'artiste rené lalique
bref comme il est mort il ya des lustres
sur genou on a fait appel un décorateur
bien vivant est plutôt doué hattrick
hellman qui a surtout dû bénéficier d'un
gros groupe mais alors très très gros
budget pour faire ce que l'on voit
franchement c'est beau et alors là c'est
incroyable parce qu on est dans une
suite donc sur deux étages au 8e étage
du prince de galles
il y à un ascenseur
bon basket apportant dans une chambre
avant toute chose dont le décor c'est
important un clip tout ça de la lente
hop ça c'est facile au moins pour les
tops puis l'autre chose qui est
importante c'est le lit mais celui-là il
a quand même l'air plutôt très
confortable et les oreillers bien sûr
ravir sa les oreillers noms sont tout de
suite que les oreillers vous prendre la
forme de la tête s'en va être trop bien
avec les trois plumeau des armoiries du
prince de galles
voilà superbe superbe la télé de très
beaux objets la piètre pour une petite
lettre d'amour
c'est idiot ça c'est quoi ça c'est le
tour
cendrier mais rien ça je sais pas
comment les gens font pour ne pas piquer
lorsqu'on dit croupit toujours les
cendriers des réseaux times c'est
vraiment un objet d'art
ce magnifique base
ces thèmes est posée sur un verre à
verlaine hyperdock ans
c'est vraiment très très bien et là mon
sac pas question de le laisser n'importe
où
dans le tas racing
un petit sac
et aussi tu deviens le g
quand on est dans une suite on ne
s'ennuie jamais il ya un bar rempli
jusqu'à la gueule un plateau de petites
douceurs plein de gadgets et une grande
terrasse avec une vue comme personne il
en a et comme tout le monde ils en
rêvent
[Musique]
et la nuit baup et noir de jolis
pantoufles pour aller prendre son bain
bon eh oh là c'est privé encore un mot
tous à un prix nos combien ça coûte de
dormir là 18000 euros pour la nuit
ah oui quand même bon
évitons de nous endormir pour en
profiter
[Musique]